all right welcome nice to see a full
room at the end of the conference I
promise I'll make it worth your time to
stick around until the end we're going
to talk about common API security
pitfalls API swell
we kind of know why you're here
everybody today is building API so
everybody's building single page
applications backed by an API maybe a
mobile application or a desktop
application but it's gonna be backed by
an API that's the way we do things how
you build that API I'm not gonna talk
about that I'm gonna talk about security
I'm gonna talk about some of the things
that might go wrong some of the things
I've seen go wrong in real api's weather
I've seen it personally or somebody else
has found it and published or talked
about it online that's what we're gonna
talk about right here why this talk
because API security is getting more and
more important when they built the AUSA
top 10 like the list of the top 10 most
dangerous web security vulnerabilities
in 2017 they proposed to add an item
place number 10 under protected api's
because it was on the rise in 2017 they
noticed like you know what there's a lot
of API sand basically security is a very
big problem in the API wrote turnout at
all stop then back then had like a big
controversy and they built a new version
from scratch which didn't include this
item but the seed was planted again back
then and then a bit later actually um
last year a group of people at OS
published API security top ten so
instead of having one item in the top 10
of that security from the build it so
you know what api's are actually kind of
different we've seen a lot more data
since then and they built a full top ten
of security issues in API so you can
find the project online it's open you
can contribute if you want to and you
can definitely use that information in
there there's ten items that occur a lot
in AP is how you can detect them how you
can fix them and so on that's what I'm
gonna talk about more or less there's
gonna be some issues that are in there
some issues that are not in there we're
gonna talk about API security just to
make sure we're on the same page let me
show you what this actually means we
have a browser and we have a server
somewhere and we're loading an
application we're loading basically the
application that we're gonna run in our
browser an angular application react
view whatever you're building doesn't
matter that application runs as an
independent client and it needs some
thing useful needs data and it needs to
perform operations and that's where the
API comes into play you have a server
somewhere an API serving data performing
operations and so on
you kind of know what we are talking
about here I hope otherwise this talk is
gonna be a very big eye-opener I'd say
to the use of api's of course we have a
browser here which can be a web browser
on your desktop laptop mobile iPad
whatever but you also have native mobile
clients or web-based mobile clients so a
lot of that applications today are just
repackaged a lot of mobile apps sorry
are repackaged web applications
it doesn't just doesn't just doesn't
look like a web app but it definitely is
one all right that's what we're gonna
talk about we're gonna talk about the
top part of the slides the API part and
this slide is actually a very good
illustration of some of the first
problems you might encounter that's
people thinking that the clients can
handle certain security responsibilities
yes some things move to the client but
never any authorization based security
decisions the client is lifts outside of
your trust boundary you have no control
over the clients and I take her to open
up the clients and make it to whatever
they want you have to assume that the
client is untrusted always a very good
illustration is when you use tinder this
is purely anecdotal ad authorized my
wife would be very mad about me talking
about this but if you use tinder you get
these blurred pictures so you can see
who else liked you and of course if you
aren't in you you might want to know
that so of course they sell you a
subscription so you get unblurred
pictures if you pay them of course if
people if IT people security people see
this they're gonna be teased like mmm I
actually want to know who likes me so
they start digging deeper and they found
that tinder on mobile blurs the pictures
on the client-side they fetched a
picture from the API and they blur it
and then display it to you so they dug a
bit deeper they opened up the web app
they figured out how the API work and
then they started sending requests with
postman pretending to be a mobile
application and he got the pictures out
just like that that's one very good
illustration of why I can now trust the
client here it's kind of harmless maybe
they even know about knew about it like
yeah that's probably not the most secure
thing you know what that's good enough
because honestly we don't care that much
about it either but you'll find this in
other instances as well you'll find
applications that serve a lot of data to
the client and then the client
cherry-picks what are gonna display like
oh we have a full JSON object we're only
going to show these two fields so it's
good but of course somebody inspecting
the data are so many inspecting the API
will quickly figure out that the data is
leaking anyway I will extract an
information one way or another and the
same thing goes with admin data admin
functionality and so on and so on and
that brings us to the very first pitfall
never rely on the client for making
authorization decisions don't over
expose data to the API because an act an
attacker always has full access to all
their API endpoints you have to assume
that authorization never leaves on the
client that doesn't mean that you cannot
do client-side authorization where you
cannot do it as an only defense every
authorization decision on the client
which is good for usability and to
detect people tampering with the
application and things like that is
useful but always make the real
authorization decisions on the backend
in the API pitfall number one we're
gonna cover quite a bunch
I only don't know how many you'll see
where we end up in the end I'm not gonna
keep count let's let's make it clear
there all right
authorization let's talk about authorize
it we're gonna talk about authorization
law so many issues are authorization
issues let's talk about another case
I like these examples not to make fun of
these people messing up but because they
show real worlds from the abilities in
real world systems built by people just
like you people that kinda know what
they're doing but make mistakes anyway
and I'm gonna try to point this out and
try to help you figure out if your
application has these mistakes yes or no
what happened here t-mobile phone
company they allowed you to access your
account their phone company and you
needed an ID to refer to your account so
if your phone company a phone numbers
for numbers are kind of unique so that's
a good identifier you might guess so
let's just use phone numbers so if I
make a call to their API it's gonna say
like the account number with my phone
number and it's gonna give me the
account information for me if I do that
with your phone number
I'm gonna get your account information
and same for you and the same for you
and of course phone numbers well they're
kind of innumerable so you can easily
grab
millions and millions of account
information just from that API endpoint
and seems like a silly problem to have
like come on who does that well
t-mobile did that but telefónica in
Spain had the same problem and AT&T in
the US had the same problem and Verizon
in the u.s. had the same problem pretty
sure there's a few others that we don't
know about that have the same problem
this is actually really really common
it's known it's it has existed in web
applications for a very long time it's
known as an insecure direct object
reference because you have a direct
object reference a phone number the ID
or whatever and it's insecure because
there's missing authorization checks and
phone numbers is one example documents
PDFs of insurance contracts is another
example this is America first American a
financial financial insurance company in
the US and they had a very long document
identifier which was a number it could
go all the way back to I think number 79
and grab all of the documents like that
from their server because there was no
decent authorization in place and this
problem seemed stupid if I talked about
this in my training courses people are
like come on
nobody does that in practice I mean how
hard is it to write proper code well
actually it's not that hard to write it
but it's hard to think about it why
because we build systems with tutorials
if you want to learn about REST API it's
gonna find something built node.js
restful api is in ten minutes I can tell
you in ten minutes there's not gonna be
any security in there that's okay
because the goal is not to learn about
security the goal is to learn about rest
end of HTTP verbs and how to do that
you'll find things like hey let's build
the to application kind of the trivial
example let's read tasks from there and
here you have a direct object reference
we're gonna get the task ID right here
out of your request
fetch the task and return it the leading
stuff same story delete the task well
you have a task ID that comes in from
the request and you can easily delete a
task and off you go that's how we build
rest api s-- and of course if you build
a system like that your first REST API
you're gonna do this and you're not
gonna deploy that in practice of course
not you know learn about authentication
after it's like oh yeah now we need
users so how do we authenticate a user
you read a few other tutorials and
implements hopefully a good
authentication system depends what you
read and essentially you'll have some
authentication in place and then you
need the mindset to think about hey
authentication is one thing but what
about access control and that's
something that's often not covered and
if you forget about access control
you're the same as t-mobile because they
did check if you were authenticated but
they forgot to check object level access
control and that's how these these
problems come into existence and these
are hard to see in an application
because it doesn't pop out it's not like
a wrong line of code no it's something
missing and unless you go in there
looking for this particular problem
you're not gonna find it there's a lot
of applications that suffer from this in
an API role we call that bola broken
object level access control it's a
different name for either but it's the
same vulnerability pitfall here lack of
proper authorization there's a lot of
applications there have always been a
lot of applications and there are still
a lot of applications built today that
may check authentication but not
authorization that's a very very common
problem what can you do against that
concretely well take your application
and audits your authorization policy
look at it like hey what do we check do
we check these things everywhere every
single like end point do we check that
yes or no chances are there are a few or
you don't check it by the way if you
want to grab a copy of the slides
they're available on my website so just
go to my Twitter or my website and
you'll find the link to the talk and a
PDF of the slides with a lot more
information than what I'm going to talk
about here in case you are interested in
that but authorization auditing policies
I want you to go into your application
and look at your policy are you gonna
find and it's not gonna be that easy
typically what I see with a lot of
customers is that authorization is there
somewhat but nobody really knows how or
what there's maybe one guy if you're
sitting together at four or five people
are at a table there's maybe one person
is like oh yeah I know how our ization
works and everybody's looking at him or
her and it's like yeah we get something
from here so we get a request to our our
back-end and request is like a token
maybe or
it doesn't matter much and maybe a
custom header for customers because we
have different tenants and based on that
we're gonna make an authorization
decision but it doesn't end there
because they have different services
whether it's a micro service
architecture or a monolids you're gonna
have different components in your
application responsible with different
things and each of these components is
gonna make authorization decisions and
that is your authorization policy you
may have an authentication check like
it's user authenticated home no he isn't
for it for a 1-ton oh the user is
authenticated
go ahead go ahead but let's perform some
operations maybe there is an object
level check maybe there there's a
customer specific functionality so you
have to differentiate between a tenant
so there's a customer check and a user
check for accessing that particular
piece of data and so on and that is what
authorization policies often look like
and other thing this is a freaking
nightmare because nobody really knows
what is checked where you need to have a
very strong and deep mental model of
what the application does rare every bit
of data comes from before we can decide
whether this is is secure policy yes or
no and honestly I don't like that
because that means if I come in to help
them with security it takes a lot of
effort to understand what they're doing
to figure out if they have full
abilities yes or no and what would be
better here is if you would have a
centralized policy
I'm not saying to take away all of these
checks and put them in one place
keep the checks because they're good
it's good to have object level access
control right here but also have a
central policy you can enforce where the
requests enter your application because
that central policy can be made
independent of the application code it's
not going to be an annotation based
thing you put in on methods and stuff
like that no it's gonna be either a
centralized component or a policy
language or whatever you're using but
it's something you can add it it's
something you can look at like what is
allowed in my application like oh yeah
that's a clear overview we can look at
that we can test against that we can
write tests against our authorization
policy only without looking at a code to
make sure that what we think is expected
behavior is actually enforced by our
policy that's a very very important one
that a lot of people just implicitly
assume from the code like oh yeah that's
probably our policy but nobody really
knows and that's a problem sometimes
all right my apologies for a bright
white light by the way I'm not used to
LED screens projecting that on to you
keeps you awake though so that's good
all right
making authorisation decisions what do
we need to do that we need to know who's
making a call we need some information
some kind of state session state
authentication state it doesn't matter
what you want to call it there's all
kinds of definitions and none of them is
really right for every scenario so I
don't care about names I care about what
it is and if you take a step back 15
years to the GS pH the pH pH asp.net you
had a server and you had a client like a
web app once River couple browsers and
that's about it and then things started
growing you had a more of a few more
clients and a few more services in the
backend we kind of knew how to handle
that
yes load balancing is not really fun
with server-side sessions but it kind of
works stateful sessions kind of work in
that scenario I'm not talking about
stateful code I'm not talking about
coated behaves differently based on a
property set somewhere in this in a
weird object no I'm talking about
keeping authorization state after the
user is authenticated keeping track of
its authentication State or
authorization State in a server-side
session object I've already put at a
memory or in a Redis cache doesn't
matter it's a server-side stateful
object and if you build api's people are
like no they must be stateless because
res says it amends is stateless and many
customers go to the pain of making that
stateless learning about all of that
figuring out how to do that often
getting it wrong to realize like hey why
did we do that because we have one
server running our API it's like that
makes no sense we only have hundred user
speed we don't have more users because
we're a very specialized application so
what's the point of doing that yes you
can technically you cannot call it a
REST API but in practice it still works
an API keeping track of State in a
server-side session just works as well
as another API of course if you're
building something like this you might
want to go for stateless approach
because otherwise load balancing is
gonna be a pain in the ass to do that
for a lot of servers
especially across different zones all
over the world that's not gonna work
very well and they're stateless
approaches do work but a stateless
approach is fastly different from a
stateful approach so make sure you do it
for the right reasons you wouldn't be
the first one that goes through the pain
of moving towards a fully stateless API
system only to realize that it didn't
need that in the first place if your
people know how to deal with cookies and
server-side session and session
replication and session our sticky
sessions why not stick to that if that
works for you again there's nothing
wrong with both approaches just make
sure you switch for your right reasons
make sure you switch for the reasons of
scalability not because some people
someone read somewhere that the rest api
is always stateless because honestly on
the web it doesn't have to be all right
back to our image from here
this is server-side sessions this is
what a lot of people hate like the
old-school PHP sessions like no we don't
want that that's ugly you know want to
keep it on our server you want to move
that to the clients easy right on
PowerPoint it's just likely move a few
circles down and you're done in practice
it's gonna be a lot more difficult in
practice this is a kind of a secure
environment if you store something in
memory on the server guess what nobody
can touch it
well somebody can touch it you have
bigger problems is somebody changing an
object on the server but if it lives on
the client if you push it to a mobile
app to a web app the attacker can be
like mm that's interesting and they can
change whatever they want meaning that
you've just changed the security of
security properties of that state and
that is up to you to protect that state
so you're gonna have to provide some
protection integrity ideally no
integrity it's gonna be mandatory
confidentiality if you need it
integrity will ensure that nobody can
mess with it without you detecting those
changes confidentiality here that data
is confidential if you put personal
information healthcare information in
there nobody's gonna be able to extract
that from memory from the server and
again if they can you have bigger
problems but here she puts health care
information here it's gonna live on
clients on browsers and you need to
protect that information you need to
ensure that it's protected against
unauthorized access
how do we do that in practice of course
with a Jason left okay Jason web tokens
have become the defect of standard
there's a few other mechanisms that
might do something similar but today
it's gonna be a JSON web token whether
you like it or not but everybody likes
them because they're very cool and
colorful like the red purple and blue
part pretty awesome can put whatever
crap you wants in a jot and it's just
gonna work and they even have signatures
well if you do it correctly but it's
gonna be hard to not have signatures in
a chat and the blue part here is a
signature and that signature offers you
integrity protection so how do you use
that well you can create a job and sign
it and push it off somewhere else for
the client for example and comes back
and all of a sudden you have a JSON web
token and you can verify that signature
you get the claims and you know that
these have not been modified that this
integrity protection here's a code
snippet of how to do that in Java my
apologies if you're not a java person I
realize this is a probably a telnet
conference but bear with me you can
probably understand what's happening so
you have a trust here the token coming
in it's of course not hard-coded is this
PowerPoint code not production code you
get that from the request somewhere and
you decode that to get the claims out
and if you do it like this
you are absolutely screwed but if I show
this example in a training course I did
at in the workshop two days ago and I
asked like what's the problem here and
you have 20 people in the room looking
at this example like hmm it takes them a
minute or two for basically one
meaningful line of code like yeah what's
good the problem me and after like two
minutes there's one person like yeah I
don't think you're verifying the
signature and it's like yeah you're
correct this is the way to do that but
this one gives you the data out of the
jot without complete complaining it's
like oh yeah here's the chart I'm
dressing a throwaway the header and the
signature take the data and give you
those claims in an object-oriented
manner awesome what you should do is
verify the signature this is decoding
its basics for decoding that's all it
does and the bottom example is actually
verifying the signature but unless you
as a developer
first of all reads the documentation
which let's be honest nobody ever does
so that's not gonna happen
and unless you think about I don't
anything with a secret here so that's
probably not the right way you might not
notice that I don't blame you for that
it means you need to know about these
things
I kind of blame the developers of this
library because they shouldn't have
called a decode it's built by a
technical person that knew that the code
is actually insecure but they should
have called it insecure decode or decode
without verifying signature because that
tells everyone exactly what it does
decode without verifying signature and
if you still write that without thinking
about what it might mean that's on you
not on the library alright pitfall here
is Miss handling client sighs session
data client-side session data seems like
as a simple thing like just push it to
the client when in reality it's not a
reality this means you will have to do a
lot of work to make this secure and that
is actually more tricky than you might
think I encounter a lot of problems with
these things and we're gonna talk about
jots for a while longer because there's
a lot of crazy things going on all right
back to Jones the purple part is the
interesting part what do you put in
there whatever you want a job this spec
is nothing more than a way to represent
claims securely they call it claims we
might call it key value pairs but this
is a claim key value you can add arrays
and objects and whatever you want it's
Jason so whatever Jason allows you can
put into a job and it's to exchange them
securely because it's signed and can be
encrypted and that's what the spec
describes how to make that work what you
put in there that's up to you you can
build anything you want with a job what
you'll find in practice is a lot of
people doing something like this this is
not a good way of doing things this is
what you'll find in a bunch of tutorials
online to implement authentication in
angular you have an API endpoint that
accepts user name and password and then
it's fel it it's gonna generate a jot a
token they call it and they push it to
the client and that is gonna be your
state this is basically replicating a
PHP session or a JSP session or whatever
in a job that's a very very bad idea
this is
often called token-based authentication
which makes even less sense because it's
not about authentications but a
propagating authentication state but
sure why is this a problem or why do
people do this because people have some
experience with traditional server-side
sessions and they hate it every fiber in
their body - like no we don't want that
because when you get a cookie it's gonna
be a cookie with a PHP session ID or an
airspeed of nuts I don't know what a
name for the cookies my apologies but
essentially it's gonna result in a
lookup somewhere in memory in a database
in a Redis cache in God knows where you
have to look it up and translate this
into what does this mean who is this
user like oh it's Philippe awesome
yeah he's allowed to make that that's
that call so he can make an
authorization decision here and give you
the response but with angular
well angular doesn't really care about
these things but with an API it should
be stateless so you have no state so you
don't have this step so shots are really
beautiful there because now you can do
this you can send a shot to the API the
API can verify the signature take the
data out like yeah it's I knew that then
your response awesome and a lot of
people implement something like this and
it's gonna work until you run in there
into a scenario where you need to revoke
a token because what's gonna what's the
lifetime of this token gonna be well
here it's 8 hours 12 hours whatever your
session lifetime is many people just
replicate that for the job like yeah
let's make it live for 8 hours probably
good there use you can get to the
working day and then by the morning
they'll be logged out and have to login
again but that's totally acceptable and
if you have to revoke one of these
tokens because if something goes wrong
this token remains valid for 8 hours if
you get a token now your neighbor steals
that two minutes later he's gonna have a
token a speller for 7 hours and 58
minutes that's a lot of crap he can post
on Facebook in your name so you might
want to kill that token like if he knew
he has that you can vote say to Facebook
like hey please cancel this token in
this scenario if somebody comes to you
and says like I want to cancel my token
you mean like yeah that's a good
question grief occasion is virtually
impossible here if you haven't
and for these upfront because you have
no control over that yeah you can try to
find workarounds and other people have
found workarounds one of the workarounds
is you can create a list of blocked
tokens revoke tokens because every token
can have a unique identifier and you can
put that unique identifier on a list and
then when the token comes in you can
check that list and see like wow this
token no he said that this token is not
valid anymore someone can accept it this
he comes to me and asked me to kill one
of his tokens I'm gonna be like oh yeah
what's the identifier of the token isn't
me like I don't know
I don't have it anymore and somebody
else has it but I don't know what it is
so that's gonna be a problem so I need
to keep a list of every token ever
issued to every user and maybe every
device so I can look up the identifier
and put that identifier on a revocation
list and then I'm gonna have to check
every time a token comes in I'm gonna
have to go to that list to check whether
this identifier the GTI claim is on that
list or not and if it's on that list I'm
not gonna accept that token and I'm
gonna get something that looks a lot
like this now we have this kind of a
stateful list keeping track of a number
of identifiers and if you have 20,000
API it's gonna have to distribute that
list to 20,000 api's or you can build a
single point that can verify that for
you so now you're building a single
point of failure in your stateless super
scalable API system and this doesn't
really work and there's a few
alternative proposals as well but in the
end it's gonna come down to a massive
problem with this setup and a takeaway
here they stopped using juts for
sessions because a child is not a
session object somebody else wrote a
blog post about this all the way in 2015
I think because that pattern was already
happening back then and when he wrote a
blog post it's a very sarcastic tone
it's absolutely amazing to read so I
highly recommend it and a lot of people
started giving him suggestions like yeah
but you can build reification like this
or like this or it was like leave me
alone people so he wrote a follow-up
blog post basically to tell people leave
me alone and that blog post has a very
sarcastic flowchart of why this will
never ever work because every flow ends
up in usability problems or security
problems
because this is not a session and if you
start building things like refresh
tokens and so on you're seriously don't
do that
the reason it doesn't work is because
you need a support system to make this
work go out this actually comes from the
Oh art Road angle a few people's sod is
in a lot and Michael we're gonna extract
this little bit I forget about
everything else and that doesn't end
well because in the word Road you have a
full supporting ecosystem to make these
things work you have refresh tokens and
you have a central authority that will
decide if it can issue new access tokens
and so on and the lifetimes there are
short ten minutes would be ideal for a
job and if you lose it that's only ten
minutes of crap on your facebook wall
instead of eight hours and that makes it
more manageable you can even reduce a
lifetime but you need that supporting
ecosystem if you want to make it work
like that it's a very very important
takeaway here back to our chops shots
well there used to be a time when you
could build an unsigned job today that's
gonna be very very difficult they're
gonna be sign traditionally you'll find
people explaining jobs with the hmx
signature that's the default load you'll
find online explain everywhere
it's like an H Mac and an H mech is
basically a keyed hash it's a hash that
takes data as input along with the
secret your secret that you use there
should not be super-secret H Maki that's
not a good secret
it also should not be in a PowerPoint
slide shown too few hundred people or
god knows how many are gonna watch the
YouTube video so be careful with that
how does an h mark work well let me show
you how it works you have the data in a
job world the data for an HVAC H makes
do all kinds of other things or have all
kinds of other use cases but in a jump
rolled it's gonna be the header and a
payload that's the input I'm gonna feed
that into an HVAC algorithm well a
library a job library is gonna do that
for you but and it's gonna take the data
as input along with your secret key
which is not super secret a tricky and
out comes an age mac like a checksum an
integrity check some of that data along
I'm gonna share that with the clients in
this case along with the data jot that's
the blue part being appended to the job
and it's gonna be sent out to the other
party and whenever a job comes back in
you get the data and a signature or the
H Mac and you're gonna recalculate at H
Mac with the secret key in the data and
if the result is the same as a signature
attached to the shot then you know that
the data was the same as well if the
result is different than you know that
something changed you know that the data
is not the same anymore you don't know
what change but we don't care kick it
out we don't want that token anymore
that's how H max works very easy very
straightforward easy to implement
because your key your secret is like a
string you match your keyword a bit
keyboard a bit and that's gonna be your
random string don't do it like that but
in reality oh no in reality it's worse
security people have looked at real
systems and they found that people use
secrets here that they copy pasted from
lock posts if I write the blog post with
super secret H Mickey they found
production systems using super secret H
Mickey as the key for agile tokens
that's a very big problem because
attackers have lists of blog post keys
that they try against chopped tokens and
the problem here is that you have a
shared secret vote for generating h max
and verifying h max and that means the
moment somebody else has this secret
they can generate arbitrary jobs which
will be valid and your application
accepts that this also means if your
application wants to share a job with
another application they're gonna be
like yeah give me your secret so I can
verify that this is felid and you'll
find people are like oh yeah right
here we go and now the other application
has the ability to generate arbitrary
John's that's not how this is supposed
to work
but many developers don't know that
there's something else besides H max
there's a second signature algorithm
that is much better it's called
asymmetric signatures but you need to
know about that they need to go to the
pain of implementing that which is a lot
less fun than H max which is why most
tutorials or people don't talk about
that a somatic signatures work like this
you have the data you push it through a
signature algorithm with a private key
and out comes a signature and you share
that you appended to the job and you
send it out and if you want to verify
that signature and I push it through a
signature verification function it's all
in libraries because you don't have to
worry about that it depends on the
algorithm being used but essentially
it's gonna spit out a true or false or
whatever your language does and it takes
this input the public key it's gonna
spit out through or false and if it's
true you know that the message has not
been changed you know that the signature
is felid and the message is not changed
compared to when it was created
awesome you even know that it was signed
by the private key belong to this public
key and if it doesn't match either the
key is wrong or the message has changed
but we don't care in that case we don't
want it and this is a much better
mechanism because this mechanism allows
you to generate shots in one place with
a private key that nobody else has it's
a private key and the public key
everyone can know that everyone should
know that
now it's probably key everyone that has
@p can verify the integrity of a job if
you choose sign in with Google for
example in the end Google is gonna give
you or if it's gonna give the
application you're signing into a shot
with your identity information it's
gonna say like hey this is free bag and
this is this Google email address in his
Google user ID and Google's gonna sign
it with their private key and everyone
the Google's public he can verify that
JSON web token that's how this is
supposed to work you need to use this
mechanism in virtually every production
use case even if you're building micro
services and you control all of them you
need to use this every service issuing
jobs needs have its own private key
because that is how you contain the risk
because if one of them gets compromised
the other ones don't Imola over like
dominos and that's very very important
so H max can only be used in a single
isolated application what application
issuing juts and consuming its own shots
yes and H makers useful there every
other use case a somatic signatures no
questions about it absolutely important
all right
if you're doing crypto you're dealing
with keys you know everyone has ever
done crypto know is that dealing with
keys is actually the real problem the
Kryptos oh I wouldn't say easy but
fairly straightforward in a jut rolled
it's not different but the spec has a
lot of provisions a lot of ways to
handle keys again something nobody ever
talks about
most people handling jobs is like yeah
hardcore the key push it in our kit repo
ever done that's like no that's not that
we have no too intense keys need to be
rotated keys need to be changed
frequently if you start using a key
today they're still using the same key
in 2025 you're gonna be in a world of
trouble because once enough data has
passed or has been processed by a key it
becomes possible to analyze or derive
information about it and so on and so on
that's the dirty details of crypto so
what this means is you need to weigh to
identify the key used to sign a job
because today I might use key a and then
we come I use key B and the verifier
needs to know what key that you use and
a simple mechanism to do that is a que
ID claim the key identifier the issuer
of the job can include an identifier of
the key that should be used to verify
the signature so if Google generates a
job they could include an identifier
that says like oh yeah I use Google's
Monday key to verify this or something
it's a string you can choose whatever
you want for that string that's an
identifier that's a simplest mechanism
available documented in the JSON web key
specification you have other mechanisms
more flexible mechanisms because this
implies that you know where to find that
key another mechanism is a gku claim and
a G can you claim contains a URL
pointing to a jason that key set
adjacent structure containing a set of
public keys
am i including that you can tell the
receiver like hey by the way you should
go here to fetch my key files and then
you should take the key with this very
long random identifier and use that want
to verify the signature that's a more
flexible mechanism because if I'm
issuing juts like this and I want to
rotate my keys I can just create a new
key pair publish the public key on this
location in that
set and send out the tokens and everyone
receiving them will know like oh you
have to go in here fetch the key verify
oh this is valid awesome
depends on what you're building with
that but that's how you exchange key
material
some people hate keys and Jason got
really blame them it's absolutely ugly
to put in there and you might want to
prefer certificate-based keys again the
spec has you covered you have an x5 you
claim which you can use to publish x.509
certificates TLS certificates basically
which also contain a public key so you
can point that certificate file and the
receiver can fetch that file and use the
key to verify that signature awesome
right this gives you the flexibility you
need to manage keys you can easily
rotate keys you can point to various
particular piece and you can make this
work and if you implement it like this
it's gonna take some effort and you're
gonna be happy once that's working it's
like a key management bit just my boss
is gonna be very happy because they
totally understand how keys and jots
work inside no I'm just kidding however
your boss it's not gonna be happy when
the attacker comes around because your
application it's now kind of dangerous
unless you told your application if you
find the G key you claim just go there
fetch the keys take the scheme it is a
key identifier I verify the signature
and accept the claims that are in there
so the attacker if he figures that out
and now send you a token with the cheeki
you claim point into evil on example
come where you'll find the keys from the
attacker then you find the key with this
key identifier which is gonna be in
there you verify the signature which is
gonna verify because the attacker has
crafted that token with that private and
sign it with this private key and
published all that key material and
you'll find applications that don't
verify or don't restrict the location of
the G key you claim they don't restrict
where they fetch information from and
that creates a wide open hole that means
you went through a lot of effort to
implement that but have created a
massive vulnerability which is not a
good thing so this is really bad you
shouldn't do that
you can try to restrict hosts like oh I
only want to load it from here or from
there it's gonna be really difficult to
lock this down that's why real world
scenarios use different mechanisms
for example open ID has a discovery
phase where you loads basically a file
from a well specified fixed location
from the identity provider so if you log
in with Google you go to accounts of
google.com slash top-level slash
operating configuration and gonna find a
configuration file and such a
configuration file will contain a URI
for the JSON web key set and will
actually point you there and this is a
very fixed configuration mechanism that
cannot be tampered with by an attacker
creating arbitrary charts
it's very very important to be aware of
these things and to prevent these
vulnerabilities you should prepare to
handle key rotation don't use the same
key over and over again rotate them
frequently and make sure you have a
mechanism to deal with those things in
practice alright let's keep you awake
here right light should add some
stroboscope effect no all right enough
of our charts let's talk about cookies
you can answer that solely fine let's
talk about cookies versus tokens the old
way of doing things cookie with an ID
that's a PHP way the dirty way nobody
likes and the cool and hip way is
authorization headers with bearer tokens
that's what angular applications
typically do what first is for
traditional applications sitting they do
some people claim that this cannot work
with an API and are absolutely wrong
there's no reason this does not work
with an API I can know because I run
systems that actually do that of course
they both have pros and cons but why
stop there why not put a child in a
cookie or token in a cookie and an ID
and authorization header we can do that
right both headers contain a string
nobody tells you what that string should
be nobody tells you what that value
should be that is something you can
decide in your applications and this
decision seems ridiculous like why
should I
of course I'm gonna use the
authorization error what are you talking
about but it actually matters a lot by
the way an ID in an authorization header
seems very strange but
she use all out reference tokens these
are basically identifiers that translate
into metadata on the server by the
authorization server so it's basically
an identifier in an authorization header
frequently seen in those scenarios but
what I really want to talk about is that
cookies are the only thing that works
really well on the web because the
browser handles cookies automatically
the browser is very compatible with
cookies and many applications don't care
about that it's like I'm saying I'm an
angular app or I react up I send xhr
requests and I can add whatever header
as I want so I don't need cookies and
you might be right
maybe maybe it works for you and for you
but maybe not for you because you're
building an application actually loads
content from a server with HTML elements
willing me the first one to load images
from a protected resource like hey these
images are private to a user and I need
to make some authorization decisions
when accessing that file and guess
what's not there when you make a request
with an image tag a custom motorisation
header there's no way to add a custom
authorization hundred to load an image
or a video or an audio file with the
HTML elements sure if you start fetching
the data separately and loading them in
there that might work but with HTML
elements there's nothing there but
cookies are there and I see this often
in real world applications where they
need to rely on this behavior
authorization on these skulls and they
need cookies for that and if you're
fully invested in the authorization
header and you'll be like oh crap we
need cookies so we're gonna add a
complementary mechanism next to this
authorization header to also send a
cookie and it's gonna be like why
and many people regret their decision to
go with the authorization header so
think about your use cases if you need
this a cookie might be a better choice
you can still put in an access token or
a jot or whatever in a cookie sure but
it's the brass you're sending this on
every request that's the differentiator
here and there's that second place where
this really happens a lot and that's
WebSocket connections because when you
open a web socket or service and defense
for that matter
you're gonna type new WebSocket with the
URL and the browser is gonna handle
everything for you
the handshake and upgrade or the the
protocol change and all of that is hand
by the browser and guess what the
browser does not send an authorization
header with your custom bear access
token what the browser does sent if they
are available are cookies so again many
people needing web circuit connections
use the authorization header and I have
to start doing this ticket system like
I'm gonna make an API call to get a
one-time ticket and at one time thinking
I can put in the URL of my WebSocket
connection so I can authorize that call
I'm not joking these things happen in
practice so again that might be one of
the reasons to consider the use of
cookies I'm not saying that cookies are
perfect they have their own set of
problems but they also have a very valid
use case in web applications just to put
this in next to each other
goat headers your boat basically headers
can contain anything you want
they're just strings cookies work really
well within a single domain if you're
accessing ten API is on different
domains cookies are gonna be your worst
nightmare stay away from them absolutely
not rotation header you can send that
anywhere you want cookies are handled
automatically which is a good thing the
authorization header well it's a good
and a bad thing because it also leads to
attacks that's for the record I need to
be clear here but the other one requires
custom code to get information out of
responses stored somewhere in the
browser and reattach it to outdoor
requests code that you need to make
decisions for and might contain
vulnerabilities and finally cookies are
always present and that's I think their
main benefit in web applications they're
present on every request sent by the
browser while the authorization header
is only present on requests you can
control probably in your JavaScript
application all right so don't
underestimate the impact of session
transport really really important I call
it session transfer because you're
transporting our authorization state or
authentication state back to the backend
one way or another we need to do that
whether you like it or not all right are
so good I have a few more not too many
one really big one and then a few small
ones here's the big one
the big one is about cross-site
scripting cross-site scripting is this
really nasty attack in web applications
everyone has it it's like an opinion
everyone has it well people don't like
it when they have it or sure anyway the
problem here is that if you store your
custom their token thingy in local
storage you'll find people arguing like
hold on you're doing what now because if
I have a cross-site scripting
vulnerability in your application I can
break in I can do local storage that
gets all the keys and then get all the
data out of local storage you ship it
off somewhere else and now I have your
access token that's a bad thing so a
fine advice like this like you know what
why not put that token in an HTTP only
cookie because then JavaScript cannot
read it and you're safe from cross-site
scripting attacks
awesome right HTTP only cookies seem
like a wonderful thing but they're
really really really nuts they hide a
symptom they look secure from the
outside sure until you push it and it's
like oh apparently it doesn't work very
well because an age to be only cookie
allows you to hide a value from
JavaScript sure good but the real
problem is across at scripting attack
the fact that the attacker can inject
code and execute that code in your
application I like to compare the three
aha to a house let's say you have a nice
house you have some jewelry or your wife
has some drawer what I'll leave it in
the middle I'm not judging anyone here
and if you put it on the kitchen table
let's call it local storage anyone that
breaks in can easily snatch the jewelry
and run away so you might want to get a
nice safe and put it in there and hide
the safes and nobody can ever touch it
awesome
but Peugeot skins kids can still get in
they can still break in they can trash
your house deface all of the walls they
can hold parties they can do whatever
they want and that's a real problem here
and taking away your jewelry doesn't fix
the fact that you should probably get
better locks or put bars in front of the
window or whatever and that's the same
with cross-site scripting once the
attacker is in you're lost
once the attacker is executing code they
can do whatever they want using OAuth or
some token service or whatever they can
just go there and get a new token and
ship that off they can show a login form
today's like oh oh you're logged out
enter credentials again in ruse it's
like okay off they go password manager
will even autocomplete it because it's
in the same domain of your application
and it looks legitimate and that's a
real problem and I cannot stress this
enough because this keeps coming up over
and over again usually I don't point out
these things by myself but if people ask
me like can you take a look at my blog
post I'm not gonna say like yeah
everything is fine if they say things
like this these patterns are often
people often worry about that for
nothing if you're building something
like this
my advice is put your crap and local
storage you know why because in Scott
it's gonna cost you two minutes to do
that two minutes and you're done and the
time you save by having to read not
having to research alternatives let's
say a day or two you can get distracted
along the way I want you to spend those
two days all learning how to prevent
cross-site scripting in your application
and auditing your code because that is
much effort much better spent on those
things that I'm trying to find a way to
hide data in an HTTP only cookie one way
or another it doesn't matter cross-site
scripting means you lost the attacker
can do whatever they want as far as
you're concerned the attacker is a
legitimate application on that point on
so try to prevent cross-site scripting
much more important all right what about
this should your API accept data like
that what do you think No
why not it sure it looks like sequel
injection well in this case I kindly
agreed because you probably expect a
number so it doesn't make sense to
accept something like this brings us
here something that a lot of people
start with I like to end with that lack
of input validation you need to have
input validation if you accept whatever
crap somebody gives you it's gonna not
gonna end very well input validation
should be as strict as possible without
triggering false positives awesome what
about this Ruby API accept that piece of
data yes
why let's see it sequel injection you
change your mind quite quickly it's like
no no sequel injection in lo sequel yeah
no except that one that's good sequel
injection the I'm messing with you I'm
totally messing with you you're
absolutely correct this is a valid email
address this is a valid email s if your
API is implement like hey let's validate
this email address and be like yeah
valid BAM sequel injection well if you
have sequel injection because of this
you have another problem I'm gonna talk
about that here but this is to show you
that input validation will never save
your but input validation cannot prevent
vulnerabilities input validation is in
unison necessary first line of defense
what I like to call to keep the crazy
out that's what it does it rejects known
bad data but in the end every
vulnerability has better countermeasures
an input validation its parameterization
for sequel queries and its ultimate
encoding for cross-site scripting and
it's gotta know what knows what for
other vulnerabilities input validation
alone will never be their primary
defense but you need to have it anyway
because you don't want five megabytes of
password data to be acceptable data you
want to reject that and say like let's
enforce a sensible length like maybe 100
characters but not God knows how many
and that is really really important to
take away what happens when chocolate
ice cream goes wrong well even my kids
know it's not ice creams okay seriously
what happens when things go wrong in a
lot of cases a seemingly silly
vulnerability in an unimportant part of
the application leads to a massive
compromise like here he's a search
feature
oh yeah crap that search feature had a
cross-site scripting vulnerability and
now our entire application is
compromised oopsie
that's not a good thing and that happens
and that brings me to the last bit for
compartmentalization or a lack of
compartmentalization you need to
compartmentalize
your applications we still think too
much about full applications split it up
in smaller parts if you have different
user levels think about building
different applications if you have an
admin part usually admin parts are very
separate they don't overlap much with
other functionality so build a separate
admin application and deploy that
application on a different host users
raster grade comm admin dot R estimated
come why because the browser understands
different hosts and domains and will
isolate them from each other and if
something gets compromised in public
that respirator come it will not affect
the other parts of the application it
will not trick an admin into logging in
in the public part because they are used
to login to the admin part and my
password manager understands that as
well I will not fill out my credentials
in public only in admin and that's
really important that's something that
today almost nobody does we still build
large applications yes it's a micro
service but everything runs under the
same domain and there's no isolation
whatsoever the browser doesn't
understand parts browsers understand
domains
well actually scheme host and port but
the scheme is HTTPS and the port is 4 4
3 so it's about domains today so
compartmentalize split things up and
question everything it's all about
asking questions and if you don't know
the answer to the question ask someone
with more security knowledge and if they
don't know the answer in your company
tell them to go ask someone else because
a lot of people are like yeah it's
probably ok we don't really know it's
gonna be fine and three years later and
the press releases like yeah apparently
we had a problem yeah you should have
asked someone I know we don't like to
admit that we don't know things but you
really that's the only way forward dare
to ask questions and if you don't know
the answer go find someone who has all
the answers that's basically my takeaway
message thank you very much for being
here thank you for staying
[Applause]